baby
[Music]
up there to find my wooden leg what's up
Mo shipping out to me yeah the r
bout dude I'm just trying to be
supportive I'm trying to find the right
Melody here our guest today from Black
Adam from multiple Netflix specials from
his hit show on Netflix mo mo Hammer
everybody my habibi
[ __ ] baby I love it look at how good we
have kind of matching sweaters we call
them Mo Money Mo Money Mo Money Mo Money
More Problems or no
um no okay
there's more money more money out yes
that's it I like I like uh uh Moe's got
you got a new glow to you babe yeah
you're just glowing hey what is that
what is it is that like some little
sweet romantic music in the background
what is that I don't know what that is
oh is that oh that's the ferry
that's not though
is that a nuclear bomb warning is that a
is that a storm
I kind of want it to be over to be
honest
we're gonna send
it
outside I kind of like it when you were
just talking about me and then like
music soft music
getting emotional right now
you've lost weight baby have I I think
so I'm trying you look you look tight
yeah uh I I I gotta be honest with you
there it is don't worry about it
I haven't seen you not dressed in full
Muslim in a while
that's that's a long shirt that's just
stylish yeah but it's fun no no no it is
no no it is I can't pull that off but I
see you there's a pattern on it yeah
that you just automatically relate to it
being an Islamic type of stress but it's
not
okay this is the long shirt it's like
from The Gap what I wore in the premiere
Toby made for me the premiere yes Toby
McGuire no no Toby wegwe he's uh you
know uh uh he's freaking killing it he's
in my TV show but he's also like uh
blowing up as a hip-hop artist in
Houston
fun last name
it's out that sounds like what my
daughter's first attempt at home
that's my brother and his last name just
throws me off all the time and in front
of it but it's silent like you're trying
to try it even if he was like a tough
gangbang
okay see this picture right see that
that to me that's a gorgeous shirt
that's a Gore-Tex jacket but it's long
yeah you're equating long textiles with
Muslims when I see length I think Israel
don't understand what you're talking
about what I like about Mo you
you have a haircut that is
fashion forward thank you you take risks
with your hair I don't I say I say it
into my box but every time I see you
you'll have taken another risk with your
hair yeah and it always works because
you own the you own it yeah I'm just
trying to do something different you
know with me yeah I don't know she got
the most walk yeah it's cool it's
stylish
the Mohawk did you see him TM how do you
write that [ __ ] no I no I don't know
what it is you talking about the one on
the right this look right here you don't
think Islam No I think that's look right
there where he's wearing the water
spoons
damn right there right yeah yeah the
shoes
that just looks like he he said who's
this other person very professional
that's good
[Laughter]
that's Moe when he puts the glasses on
yeah
this is very old this is very old
um this is unfortunate this pops up yeah
let me tell you something keep going
find something else yeah how great is a
TV show
it's gonna be season two right you don't
even have to it's we just know right
well if could you imagine there was in a
season two
um you know it depends on what's
happening with my career and stuff you
know if there wasn't a decision it would
be up to you because it was everything
it's a hit that's what I'm saying I mean
it's like it's been reviewed so well
it's 100 of rotten tomatoes and the
audience score is equally as strong it's
just pretty
she's the best it's just wow it's really
really great man it's resonating with
people like in a really special way and
the thing is is like you know you have
you have a lot of variables at play and
let's just see what happens you know
right now I'm just enjoying it I'm in
the movie Black Adam with The Rock and
I'm just letting it's opening this
weekend it's a rock smell like
um just pineapples good right fresh oh
is that means
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know what you're talking about
either so supposedly if a person's
wearing a pineapple on them like a
pineapple jewelry or pineapple that's
undercut vanity saying yes because I
guess she's in the club
my friend has been invited it's always
convenient to friend what's your
friend's name Quick Melissa you made it
up you made it up take away you're like
uh
I think you have a pineapple uh and
outside and it means like Hey we're open
to swinging yep or pineapple wallpapers
another one SpongeBob just to [ __ ] fest
down in the ocean
my grandmother my whole life had
pineapple wallpaper now I know no
yeah
that's amazing the pineapple has
injected itself into like housewares and
pop culture like like you know it's a
thing now this pineapple earrings this
pineapple shirts it's pineapple
wallpaper there's a pineapple [ __ ]
thing like a I see all the time people
are buying pineapples and not knowing
that they're sending off the wrong
message because it's a sex fueled
Society yes that's what's happening and
that's what Moe's trying to change no
yes yes
the key party a key part is when you got
to a party right in the 70s and you all
everyone put their key in a bowl and
then you pick the key out and whoever's
key you picked out is that who you had
sex with no what are you talking about I
don't know a key party I don't know you
know about Pines you guys are [ __ ]
freaks man what are you talking about a
key part
a couples party where all the men put
their car keys into a bowl or a bag at
the end of The Party The Women blindly
select a set of keys to determine who
she goes home with for the rest of the
evening for sexual gratification
and it's used in a sentence last time I
got to take Jerry's wife Sue home
the key Parts with me let me tell you
something if your wife's name is Jan
she's probably not sucking
easily I could have told you that no
problem but she makes a mean pineapple
pie yeah she does yeah she does
never heard of that Jan went home with
Bill and said she liked how large his
penis was but that I still make better
love to her than any of her other
partners so there you go Bill's got a
nice big dick oh my God what did I sign
up for today welcome to hey hey babe
before the show I'm like no we don't
talk about any politics we're a very
clean podcasts we don't nothing he's
like nothing right away something
pineapples
right away where's your Muslim attire
and who blows you correct
hold me Sal
right away
it hasn't only been five minutes I mean
this guy's already breaking into this I
know oh you want to talk about happy
marriages yeah uh pull up the thing I
texted you uh from uh the courtroom no
no the other thing what's up guys big
announcement first of all the IJ tour is
going on right now the pre-sales is
going on right now uh and they go on
sale Friday morning uh which is tomorrow
morning and it is the pre-sale code is
IJ Drive we're coming to a ton of cities
so go to
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets
and then come see your boy uh October
28th I'm in Richmond Virginia October
29th two in Hershey in Pennsylvania and
then the following weekend we got
Knoxville November 11th two in Atlanta
on November 12th and Alabama Birmingham
November 13th everything on sale right
now at savocano comedy.com I'll see you
there beautiful beautiful and then I got
a brand new hour of stand-up material 0
go to chrisdcomedy.com October 27th in
Baltimore November 17th 18th Toronto and
the big one December 31st Huntington
Long Island the Paramount New Year's Eve
show two shows it is on sale tomorrow
tomorrow the pre-sale is happening now
uh but it's almost over so it is on sale
tomorrow pre-sale code if you want is
Chrissy Nye uh I believe and uh but go
get those tickets tomorrow
chrisdcomedy.com
I saw this this week oh you're not
wearing socks yeah I'm wearing socks I
want to buy a monster well Moe's got low
cut socks on it always freaks me out
when a person doesn't wear socks it's
disgusting in someone's home or in there
like no no right now in walking shoes
he's bipedal for the day and he's
wearing low socks from this angle
shows yeah yeah without my podcast
Chrissy Kay it's yesterday yeah yeah
well I told you later on in the episode
I'll tell you how we're connected yeah
okay
um watch this clip I saw this clip this
week and I immediately said first thing
I'm doing is taking this on hey babe
okay okay I can't wait this is no the
first thing you said is you're taking
this up with Bloom Cafe that's right
take it up a boom Cafe
over 20. look at him though he looked
mad
I'm almost Happy doesn't it
you don't look happy
point
s
[Applause]
he's very happy tournament Chow a former
TV show bailiff and current Harris
County Deputy charged with his wife's
murder now ordered not to attend her
funeral Bernard Spivey appeared before
done oh my God
[Laughter]
he literally
oh my God I can't even laugh bro this is
like shocking to me
because she sounds like a Houston uh
anchor honestly that guy is so diesel
it's like one little flick you know I
was shocked when I saw that yeah it is
it is it says NRG Stadium in the
background is that is anything in
Houston yeah dude holy [ __ ] Houston dude
man I'm so sad for her family though
that's [ __ ] up oh no of course like
they were talking about sucking dick and
yeah
I mean the the bailiff from television
Court killed his wife no people listen
people uh I think that when I what to be
honest with you when I saw that guy when
I saw him I was like he's first of all
he's on steroids you can't look like you
can't have such a small head and big
biceps sure you're on roids so I was
like this guy could potentially kill his
wife I've kind of felt like I mean look
at his forearms nobody saw that coming
what are you talking about yeah you
didn't see that company
I thought the whole clip was just the
funniness of him go and tell him you
don't look happy and everyone's laughing
so I thought that was the end of the
clip and it just comes up
his guys but a guy like this in jail I
wonder if he's even scared to go to jail
of course he's gonna do with that guy I
remember being in high school and they
brought these like inmates in to talk to
you just get straight he had to scare
you straight or whatever and then I was
like you think you're a big guy there's
always someone bigger than you and they
showed all these pictures of all these
different inmates and it was just
terrifying you see how big you can get a
guy serving life in prison is just in
there just it's all he does eating
[ __ ] noodles and weights bulking up
like you would not believe and it's just
monsters yeah of course he's gonna get
we one time on the show they had me do a
Scared Straight punishment and they put
me in a you know prison jumpsuit they
put the bandana on me they tatted me up
I had a teardrop on my face all that
stuff what yeah this is School no no on
the show
to go to a school to go to a school yeah
there it is
funny you look like you look like a male
inmate dressed to go to a women's jail
so they put these pair of glasses on me
that were blacked out and they told me
to go in the room and just scare
straight and I didn't know I was in a
senior citizen's home and I just started
screaming at the old days what do you
mean so you can't see out of those
glasses yeah those glasses
at one point
I say if you come to prison if you come
to prison that I'm writing a phone in
space I go that means you want a good
old-fashioned
and then right before it I was done they
made me lift the glasses off and I saw
the room and then to get out of the room
it was an elevator and I went and pushed
the elevator button and it took a while
to come back
oh my God I love it oh god
oh
we can't show this clip the fans we
can't show this sorry guys oh we can't
even show it oh really damn it oh we'll
get flagged right this is crazy that's
on Comedy Central it's not even where
it's on yeah that's so it's probably
it's a more on Comedy Central in the UK
that's why they put it on there are you
gonna move to New York or L.A you're
just gonna stay in Houston
um you know I'm in Houston just I mean
Houston is always home so I'm always
going to have that uh spot and used to
watch my family's my mom is so I'm not
going to move from there but I spend
more time outside of Houston than I do
in Houston anyways yeah I feel like
you're never in you're just you're
always somewhere yeah so what's the
point you know what I mean like why move
here and do that I'd just rather stay in
the hotel
it is I'd rather just be in a hotel and
enjoy it and not have to worry about
like an apartment or something like that
or just we were in Houston how did
everything with those those flood of
flooding go I mean it doesn't happen as
often as you think I mean we've had like
you know hurricanes that came through
that they had that big big one though
yeah
2017. that was the big one yeah we had
the freeze last year like at Texas
freaks the world is ending I mean who
the [ __ ] has a freeze in Texas what are
we gonna do for an entire week we no we
just the Earth is going to restart and
we're just gonna go away I mean that's
what's gonna happen whoever survives
survive baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
Yellowstone's gonna blow up you know
they got a huge volcano they say it's a
super volcano that'll blow up the whole
world well Seattle's supposed to fall
off off the earth when in Seattle it's
overdue can you believe that how is it
hundreds of years overdue according to
to Quake an earthquake it's supposed to
break off and fall into the ocean
Seattle I thought that was California
yeah I thought that was La Google
Seattle
the really big one let's Google it look
like a giant Seattle earthquake this is
what Kurt Cobain the news Kurt Cobain
found out
that's why he was like [ __ ] 100 I
mean an earthquake in New York would be
disaster you know what I you know what I
learned you know you saw making me
America's a big natural disaster place
you go to other places like like in
Ireland there's they don't there's no
natural disasters they don't get
hurricanes no they get a little bit of
flooding in there no Quakes no
hurricanes it's almost saying like Jesus
typhoons or anything no they don't get
it just mudslides no not really
sinkholes they might get sinkholes well
they're stuck in Ireland though
I told you first of all my sweaters from
Ireland shout out the iron Island I love
Ireland dude Ireland shout out cable
knit sweaters oh green sweaters in
general
what companies
uh I don't know I like it dude it's like
it's like it's like you're saying you're
you're coming you're like a metrosexual
Soldier yeah
are you guys ready you're in a war with
get your pineapples out everyone here's
a fish bowl of keys dude it did not not
blow your mind that way that that uh uh
pineapples are swingers now you know it
doesn't even make any sense to me Mo I'm
telling you tonight go out and start
dangling a pineapple outside your hotel
window watch how many swingers you are
going to come show up I'm gonna do it
see what happens I'm going to open the
door and shame them I love you does your
mother know what you're doing wait scoot
over yeah come here
you
I love Moe and and because Mao is from
Houston I love Houston but I hate the
Houston Astros why because I hate them
because they beat you all well no yes
because they're cheaters they're they're
dirty cheaters and I don't stand for
cheating yeah
Jose
tomorrow
he's I love him I'm very close to the
Astros organization and I love them I
was in the airport I was in there like I
do they take care of me man they're like
really great and growing up with the
Killer Bees and then they're [ __ ]
always getting trampled by the Braves in
the first round I know now the points
are 90s Are You Gonna Go are you gonna
go to any Houston Astros playoff games
hell yeah I'm trying to just the
schedule touring and stuff but yeah yeah
but they're they're going to start I go
to every game when I was filming my show
last year was during the playoffs they
do have a beautiful stadium and I would
film it was so much fun the juice box
they call it the nickname for it is the
juice box Aaron judge you talking about
New York Yankees cheat it cheat like
crazy don't cheat
don't
cheats
they were steroids anymore Aaron judge
is six yeah all right he's just six
eight in just a month there's no way I'm
sorry
I'll love tearing judge
have the same haircut
no the Astros are dirty rotten cheese
all right and you know what I don't
[ __ ] want to hold this anymore
just kidding it's cute Astros
nobody knows what an asteroid is
relating to this exactly
get the Rockets what is the connection
to to Houston
yeah I guess so oh you wouldn't mean you
guess so it's nasty but they're basing
everything around that now
your whole identical identity now is
Aeronautics okay so mix it up what do
you mean Yankees the metropolitans The
Knickerbockers the Islanders the Rangers
I mean we have what do we have the
Texans the Oilers
the Oilers was the best thing
yeah
that over the starter jackets
who was it Warren Moon yeah oh my God
warm Moon my childhood hero and I met
this guy you met Warren Moon yeah it was
Minneapolis leaving a gig it's like four
o'clock in the morning I look over to
myself checking out no I was leaving I
was it was like a 6am oh you went up
early for a flight yeah
I look over those they're just fans I
love it I look over to the left I see
War moon in Minneapolis because you
don't play for the Vikings so I assume
he was visiting or whatever I look over
I was like oh [ __ ] more moons I was like
22 maybe 23 you know I look over and I
like look I don't bother you know super
early uh short time from Houston thank
you for all the memories and I go to
shake his hand like this and I'm wearing
Moon you're me okay wait you're warning
I'm wearing Moon Chris you're a Moana
um
goes like this
oh like a like uh inside like he's
carving something like what is oh he
might want him to he might have wanted
to do it yeah he doesn't have a Super
Bowl ring maybe he just wants you to
kiss his finger I could maybe he's a
pineapple maybe he is a pineapple it was
just really odd I couldn't see it yeah I
don't like you got to give a strong
handshake Warren Moon though by the way
fits well in Houston at Celestial good
level wow I never even made that
connection all these years there we go
baby no it was great
he had to play in the Canadian football
he's still like a hero I mean like him
for representing as a black quarterback
in the NFL he was like one of the early
ones to make such a big impact and then
he was playing in Canada for years they
say if he didn't play in Canada just
played in NFL the entire time he would
have the most yards it wouldn't even be
born
I didn't know that I thought Warren Moon
got like drafted up as a rookie no no no
no no he played in Canada for for a bit
and then he moved down to the NFL to
pick them up the Houston Oilers did and
went on for a phenomenal career guys
Beast unfortunately we lost the Buffalo
Bills that 35-3 when you guys cheated
when you you know the bills cheated do
you ever think about you being a
Palestinian BB stepped out of bounds you
came back in you guys don't remember
this Don BB let me just tell you he
didn't put the head down he still
[ __ ] made it there the the holding
call that was turned into interceptions
[ __ ] man Don BB's stupidest helmet
in sports Don BB's helmet looks stupid
on his dumb head Don BB's helmet his
helmet was too big for his head
how much
[Laughter]
but he knew in advance
no that's because he's wearing two
elements
seriously it's enormous he's got a
helmet on under that I remember one time
I swear to God watching I think it was
one of the Buffalo Bills Super Bowls
where they went four in a row and I
remember watching the game with my mom
only one foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
Master Flex night
with Shopify you'll create an online
store in your Vibe discover new
customers and grow the following and
grow the following that keeps them
coming back Shopify offers 24 7 support
and free libraries full of educational
content shopify's got you my man every
step of the world you can shop Shopify
makes it simple to sell from to anyone
from anywhere Shopify said to your mama
Shopify your mama your mama and his mama
and his mama that's what they do listen
Shopify if you don't have a Shopify
business I'm telling you you're like
you're not running your business as
efficiently as it can be Shopify
literally they go hand in hand if you
run and operate a business you need to
have Shopify it literally makes ordering
simple it's awesome they have 24 7
support and free libraries of all
educational content so they're with you
every single step of the way uh when
you're ready to launch your own uh thing
into the spotlight try Shopify the
Commerce platform backed by millions of
businesses uh down the street and around
the globe stop aren't selling everywhere
for free with Shopify right now sign up
for a free trial at shopify.com hey babe
all lowercase go to shopify.com hey babe
to start selling online today
shopify.com hey babe uh yes Sunday this
past Sunday I put 250 into my DraftKings
app you did yes good and I and I and I I
played I I bet on like five games
it is fun because I'm already like I try
to keep Sunday for the Lord and for
football yes and I watch and I make a
sauce or chili it's like I relax it's
Sunday is my day of rest you're my Nona
I am like your Nona you know the same
body and everything and uh what I do is
theater yeah I know but you know what
watching football I already love it but
when I have a little bit more fun I have
a little more fun when I have a little
something a little action until I got
news for you baby yeah Sunday football
great we all love it but now the NBA is
starting oh they have everything
race car they're the official sports
betting partner of the NBA 25 NBA a
money line bet and you get two hundred
dollars in free bets if your team wins
do you understand how crazy that is wow
that is crazy check this out in addition
to the usual bets everyone can boost
their winnings up to 100 with DraftKings
stepped up same gay parlay oh wow when
listen DraftKings Sportsbook is where I
go to bed on the NBA right now if you
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
right now use the promo code hey babe
you make any five dollar bet this week
you will get two hundred dollars in free
bets if your team wins only at
DraftKings Sportsbook with the promo
code hey babe you're minimum age and
eligibility restrictions applies he
showed notes for details wow I should do
that
see just use that promo code yeah I'm
gonna do that please do friend one day
my friend walked into the house and his
wife was in the house and he had on like
a red a red jacket he walked in his wife
does not know or watch sports okay keep
that in mind she does not watch sports
she does not know Sports she does not
know okay he walked in with a red jacket
and she was in the kitchen she turned
around and said to him that looks like a
jacket that Mike Tomlin would wear
he was like what because
she lives in New York how does she even
know she doesn't know football never
mind the Steelers head coach never mind
what his fashion would be off the field
and what where does it come from he did
to this day he does he doesn't know just
out of nowhere he we died laughing at it
but she said that looks like Mike Tomlin
sounds fishy bro yeah we need to
investigate this further
what is this dude it's literally I'm
telling you man the the or you ever like
like people like like Google Carlos by
Erica hat his hat looks his hat was too
mean this guy couldn't smell BBQ
[Laughter]
r-g-k hat okay
[Laughter]
he's [ __ ] dumb head man that is high
and tight that speaking of this stupid
hat we should talk about the stupid hat
winner look at the stupid hat maybe he
hasn't throw under there
I ordered this from Bodega in Boston
I ordered it with a bunch of stuff I got
some kicks I got some shirts and I
ordered this and it just came in the
mail and I put it on and I was like who
is this so we had a contest
who is it for who is
I don't know
the cats are people that have been in
bad accidents somebody that got half
their head blown off
they need fashion too I guess oh my God
it's a Veterans Day
oh no so we want a shout out because we
did do we have the the info what is this
so what we did what we did uh MO is we
had someone do because we we talked
about how how stupid this hat was on
eBay put the hand on and we had you
wanna put that handle I don't really
okay just put it on it's a new way
Whenever there it is it actually looks
good on mouth well because they have the
curls the Hat has just enough depth to
only cover your curls yes it like it's
just yeah yeah we have a misshapen head
it actually doesn't the bestest Hat's
ever looked it's on you right now
because I have my curls up I have my
curls up so they're put it on because
they've come together yeah
he looks like uh he looks like a
challenged a soldier from like the 1920s
you look like that kid from The Sandlot
when he went and grabbed the Hat the
first day this is all so long
so so what we had was somebody do the
hashtag Hey babe stupid out we have the
fans make put it put it in like put tuck
your hair in oh that's when that's when
you really looked your most uh
questionable yeah what is that whoever
made this hat should be your slapped
seriously it's a cool house I think it's
the style and and by the way Bodega got
in touch with me and and gave me a
refunded me for that refunded you for
the Hat they heard the they heard the
clip and they were funded oh my God they
should they should refund everybody
[Music]
look I all love and respect you know
what I mean but this is just the best
it's like maybe Tyler the Creator wears
that kind of hat I know Tyler the
Creator
who's openly gay right yeah no I have no
idea go Tyler the Creator didn't he say
he was openly gay no I thought I shot
him out no no no no no no I thought he
was I thought he I genuinely thought he
was openly guy
um I don't know that's ambiguous
make a post saying he was openly gay I
think he I just saw him no no
girlfriends yeah
no I mean I guess he's bi then all right
now regardless shut up
he's one he is actually one of the
greatest creative minds I think in the
last like 10 10 years he's brutally
honestly he's very straight yeah yeah
um so what we did he walked Tyler the
Creator walked in the green room once I
was some tour with Dave with Chappelle
and he comes in the green room and he
has all this you know Chinese food
that's been sitting there for a little
bit and he eats some of the chicken he
goes this chicken is terrible like just
[ __ ] it I'm like yeah it's been sitting
out there for like an hour and a half
two hours to go Chinese food it's not
gonna be good if you eat it two hours
later two nights ago you know Dave
Chappelle this week this episode comes
out Thursday so last weekend Dave
Chappelle just did a pop-up midnight
show at Radio City Music Hall just a
pop-up two days Advanced pop-up two days
notice Mo did a spot just doing a little
pop-up did he did he get the six
thousand oh he sold it out yeah sold it
in an hour yeah there you go what is
Dave and Tyler Creator talk about what
is that green room no he came man he was
in Austin I think we were doing shows in
Austin and he just he happened to be in
Austin at the same time so he just came
through it was just popped in and said
this chicken is terrible he literally
left like five minutes later oh my God
oh my God
this chicken is terrible I think I think
Chappelle is like one of the most
referenced guys in recent hip-hop 100 I
don't know how many other has songs just
keep coming out with Dave Chappelle's
name on it it's really wild you know
Dave Chappelle
um no I don't know him I know I met him
a couple times he knows of me he knew of
me one time one time we were in Dayton
Ohio and I went to bed after Hometown
right nice
and I went to bed and uh and then mer
went out it was when I was on tour with
the guys and he bumped into Chappelle at
a club and uh and he's like he texted me
he's like come to the club Chappelle is
here he knows the show I'm literally
hanging out with him and stuff and I was
like I I sh in hindsight I should got up
and I should have went yeah but I was
already in bed like 40 minutes yeah
that's too late and I was just like
another day
like like when I spoke to a couple days
ago I was like oh what are you doing
tonight you're like I'm gonna go to the
SNL I'm gonna go SNL then the after
party then I'm doing Chappelle Radio
City and just his schedule I was like
I'm exhausted yeah just thinking about
it like I feel as if I feel like I'm an
old 38 and you're like a young 40.
so you're like like and I sometimes
regret like I'm like well I when I get
into my 50s maybe when my kids are older
will I just get a spring of energy
because I feel I think it's because I
don't have any kids
on children I know you know friend like
dear friends of mine that are in their
early 30s they have kids they're like
gray and just like exhausted I think
it's because of the kids although I have
a ton of nieces and nephews that I look
after and a friend yeah I want you to
have a kid and ruin your life what's up
man
I can't wait I want you to be as tired I
can't wait I don't know what I'm saying
I would love to have children for sure
I'll have your kids for you I'll be your
sir get down let's do it
you're halfway there
you could be a surrogate Dad yeah I'm
guaranteed get Dad yeah by the way the
person who made the clip that won the
hey babe had her name is Wendy shines
yeah um editing jack237 on Instagram
you're the winner we are going to send
you this hat
um where and Sal and I are going to spit
in it yeah should we sign it the inside
of it let's just sign it well I already
signed it that's why I put the sticker
45. let's see is there a video here
that's attached to this situation
I mean we got 20 20 25 30 25 30 uh uh uh
submissions they have to recreate a
scene from a a conversation from the
show we don't have to watch it but she
she literally just did go to editing
jack237 her post from September 21st go
check it out she killed it she did a
full edited scene like she she was like
a director you should sign her up for
the season to a mo she should direct
season
are you gonna get Ball wall in season
two of Mo he's in season one oh
literally you were just talking to me
about this organically factor I order
Factor I'm ordering it right now I'm 10
meals and six juices a week
wow yeah sometimes you get you
you see full for almost the entire day
it's unbelievable it's you throw it in
for two minutes it's fresh it's sealed
throw it in for two minutes you eat it
and honestly it's like it's so there's
always a protein uh and a vegetable and
usually something else and it's just
dude I eat it and I'm like I'm literally
full all day I love it and I thought my
day with a little strawberry banana
smoothie wow and they got a pumpkin
Feast now did you know that I actually
have look at this save at the harvest
season with factors pumpkin Feast for
two featuring Falls most crave flavor
pumpkin ready to eat bundle helps you
make the most of autumn with the full
spread that feeds to date night anyone
yeah
need more protein now you can add
protein to select vegan and veggie meals
there's over 30 meals that you can get
on 36 add-on options juices snacks it's
really really cool it comes to the Dory
it comes um in one box and it's all it's
all freeze-dried and I pop it out and
it's like it's good for one calendar
week so I get enough for the whole week
I put it in and then on Wednesdays I get
my new delivery Julian calendar
Gregorian uh I
Dorian is where I live got it yeah okay
okay just want to make sure because
people out there counter the week means
different whatever you want if you want
to use the Julian calendar I'm not here
to tell you not to not only does Factor
offer fast Simple Solutions when I need
the most they also help me stay on top
of my goals which is hard to carve out
time with offerings like Protein Plus
and keto I say on track just like you
said you get what's the there it is
factorized Endless Options however you
like to eat you choose the keto calorie
smart vegan veggie whatever Plus yes
what's the discount pimp I want there it
is head to go dot
factor75.com Hey babe60. listen to me he
cannot make it easier listen
your work with Factor they want you even
burning calories going on the website
figure this out this is the website you
listen
head to go dot
factor75.com hey babe60 and you see the
code hey babe 60 to get 60 off your
first box that's code hey babe 60 where
6-0 at go dot
factor75.com hey babe six zero to get 60
off your first Box 60 that's more than
that big it's more than half or I come
ten percent more than half yeah
literally Sal just gave me a box from
this place called beard Club I cannot
wait to try it all I've heard let's see
it all I've heard is that beer Club
delivers Quality Hardware and
consumables that'll help you get a
better thicker and Fuller looking beard
thick beards are in their hot they're
sexy I know and I and I wish I had one
but I have oil from them to rub on I
have they also have some vitamins to
take I have a roller to help stimulate
growth they send me all this stuff all
right now right now I have a cedar balm
in my basement it smells like a fresh
Forest here's vanity on my beard giving
me beard
here it is and the dude the dudes at
Beer Club I forget his name but shout
out uh thank you for the for the for the
missive you penned beer and Scruff cream
let's smell it
oh my literally smells amazing yeah go
ahead smell that yeah um then we got the
oh look at this the beard Club comb yeah
nice that's nice I like that oh that
feels nice on the Foss no matter what
type of bee you have beer club that has
the perfect kit for your needs and they
have over 2 million beards served uh
check it out there's so many products I
got mustache wax yeah oh I have a beard
shampoo as well I swear to God they have
a beard shampoo that I that I use grow
your best beer today and take 20 off
your first order when you go to
beardclub.com hey babe and use code hey
babe that's beardclub.com hey babe and
use code hey babe for 20 off your first
order I'm not full of [ __ ] I have a
beard shampoo and I think you'll like it
too watch CoCo melon with a [ __ ] gun
you know
but like my other Netflix I had it on
you know you better get into Coco milk
dude the whole thing
final episode that's what I'll do it in
front of the kids
you you gotta you have to learn to love
Coco melon otherwise you you only
torturing yourself can I tell you
something right what about watermelon my
daughter my oldest daughter who's seven
[ __ ] lunatic okay do you know what
she want you know what we did all
weekend you would think oh you know my
baby's watching Coco melon you know they
watch even my 12 year old stepson he
watches you know like little anime
cartoons and all that he's into like you
know like you know that that face my
daughter you know what she wants to
watch The Ring The Ring two The Watcher
the movie Grudge she watches this [ __ ]
no okay so there's at seven at seven and
it's not just some crazy imagery she
laughs at the ring she's like look at
how stupid this is Daddy and I'm
literally to I swear to Christ I have
not for the past 48 Hours been able to
pee in the middle of the night because I
am terrified of walking to the bathroom
because I think I'm going to see Samara
from The Ring calling up the stairs I
have not even I I just hold in my pants
I'm gonna walk into the bathroom so you
protected Delilah in the middle of the
shoot Delilah went downstairs at one
o'clock in the morning and got herself a
glass of water the other night is that
something seven year old zoo no my kid
doesn't give a [ __ ] wow what do you
think she's gonna be when she grows up
as a profession what do you think she's
going to be Delilah yeah yeah how do I
think Delilah is going to be I think
that I think that she probably well she
probably won't she already wants to go
in entertainment she tells me on a
weekly basis how much better she can do
my job she's like I'm better than you
and I'm like you are she's like I can't
use that kind of believe that yeah yeah
I mean she comes from you so she's gonna
have all his abilities she has a swag in
the attitude yeah and the fearlessness
you know what she said to me the other
day I swear to God we're sitting there I
said something silly to Jazz right and
Delilah didn't laugh
and I was like oh you think that one was
funny and she goes TT Jerry does it
better that's what she said to me so she
was saying to me basically she was like
I know TT Jerry is is you're you're
using TT yeah
but she so there's you ever seen the
show to watch did her mother's feeding
her these lines
I'm kidding I'm kidding so there's the
show there's a terrifying show to watch
her on Netflix right terrifying and and
in in in the thing The Watcher in the
show The Watcher when when the Watcher
reads the letters they have this like
distorted voice it's like hello I am the
Watcher reading you know I watch your
house it desires young blood and Delilah
will wait to her older brothers in the
shower and she'll turn the lights off
and she'll go Tristan is in the shower
you're freaking me out but she does
she's one of those kids she doesn't she
is not scared of anything like and then
and and to the point where they know
what a [ __ ] I am there was a loud noise
in the house a couple of weeks ago and
Delilah yelled from the from her bedroom
she was like Mom go see what that noise
was because she just knows I'm not gonna
go down the stairs and check it yeah
[Music]
she needs to be jolted how about this
she needs to put she needs to knock she
needs to be knocked down a peg this is
this is the director I really believe
this is direct influence Delilah the
advocate for this month no she's a
monster
no my my daughter's birthday is May 19th
right yeah I got an offer to do Radio
City May 19th right so I say I accept
the offer right this is all good I'm
like I'll do Radio City May 19th great
whatever telling Delilah and the family
oh we're gonna do Radio City I said
Delilah we're gonna have everyone six
thousand people God willing we sell it
out sing Happy Birthday to you and her
response was oh so you're just gonna
make my birthday about you I swear to
cry I swear to Christ the date now is
changed to October I had to give up May
19th Radio City because my daughter was
like you're just gonna make my birthday
about you that was her response to me
and I was like that's perceptive I was
like I was like I was like I was like no
I know she do that I was like no I'm not
making your birthday about me we're
gonna sing happy birthday she's like
yeah but it's your show I want to have
my own party about me I was like what
the she watched 11 years old she watched
a lot of Dr Phil or something yeah I
don't understand how she even made that
correlation
she's a sick [ __ ]
it's incredible you're trying to do
something beautiful and inclusive yeah I
thought it was a sign from from God oh
May 19th your daughter's birthday this
will be a big moment for you for a
family blah blah blah God willing goes
well and and she says it's about you
isn't it you know what she's not really
wrong you know to be honest with you
it's like it's her birthday and you're
trying to make her feel better that
you're working on her birthday look
honey trying to massage this it's what
you were doing you massage right through
it yeah I was like Delilah you know I'm
sorry look I'm gonna I'm gonna make this
whole thing it's my knight of course was
selling out 6 500 seats whatever it is
and it's gonna be that we're gonna have
them all sing Happy Birthday to you like
no no you don't [ __ ] fool me yeah
you're not gonna try to change these
around and make this and I was like
Delilah I was like way to go now if we
don't sell in October it's on you
because the whole plan was to get on the
radio press tour those extra thousand
ticks to eat that sells Delilah's
birthday party feel good blah blah blah
my daughter [ __ ] so now you just
[ __ ] us on the bonus so you're not
going to Disney yeah you're using her
exactly right
she's like I don't need you I go to
Disneyland by myself well I say well now
what guess what Delilah now I'm gonna
have to roll out TT Jerry
all right so you want to talk we were
just talking about being scared the ring
yes okay this is this is perfect okay
this is real this is real I don't
believe it's real I'm telling you this
is real why how do you know because a
friend of mine okay sent me this her two
friends by the way a friend of yours is
a friend of ourselves so one of our
friends
one of our friends
okay okay these are two people that she
knows and they were in their apartment
doing this this is what happened they
moved out the next day okay this is
confirmed what state what state where is
this Houston do we know
unfortunately that I do not know you
don't know the state I'm gonna tell you
I could find something apartment I'm
gonna tell you that they're in New
Jersey okay
Christmas lights could be Oklahoma City
so it's only 10 seconds
they notice this after the fact confirm
you know these people I know the first
person who sent me this knows them okay
and if the person I said sent me this
I've known 20 years and she's one of my
closest friends well watch closely okay
yeah no problem they didn't they didn't
this is after the fact they saw this
they when they looked back at the video
they saw this I'm just wondering if she
has a pineapple in front of her door
they're playing that game with them
I missed it what was that around watch
it again tell me it was around her hand
right they're playing that game when you
dropped a ring on the hook but yeah
oh the person walking by they don't that
they're only two of them in there they
don't live with anybody else no one else
is in the house let me let me break it
down again pause it go a little bit more
they don't that's in that whatever
whatever that is they don't live with
anyone nobody else was there and they
don't live with anyone they moved out
the next day
what was that yeah man you got to say
prayers right after that bro you can't
mess around with what was the prayer can
we say it out loud I say uh yeah
it's like um
nothing to do with Optimus look at this
Arab Christians too I'm sorry and they
all say say Allah Allah is just a word I
wash my feet every day yeah that's very
important though seriously people don't
watch that's why I learned it yeah
no I'm just basically like you know
asking for protection from God and then
you're you're basically anything evil
that comes from the devil if you believe
in that obviously and you know there's
well babe because you the whole thing is
you don't know if it's good or bad right
and you don't have to move out they
don't have to move out I've had
experiences where I've been in my house
um and all of a sudden I hear like knock
like over time like over a week I heard
like knocking like teasing then I heard
that it was the first front door like
click clack opening and then I heard the
door close and I thought it was my
stepdaughter's you know before I got
divorced and I was looking around I was
like yo what was that I was like Elise
are you there like just nothing this
door and then it's like laughing and
then more knocking bro I shut the whole
place down just turned on there's a
particular you know recommendation that
my teacher tells me you just play this
particular suit up this pretty good
chapter her I had a blasting all
throughout and you hit every corner in
the house it was gone
I'm gone never never wait a second wait
a second so you're saying if you had a
like let's say you live in a let's say
you live doesn't matter where you live
you get an apartment but I'm just saying
if you had a three-floor house right and
there were apparitions going around like
that
stay in that house alone like at night
like just and because you because the
ghost you don't care about a ghost
you're like then I don't like that
wouldn't scare you because if you were
more scared of like a real person I've
been elected in in 30 minutes after this
hilarious I would immediately start
doing what I was told like to do what
happens before like you have to read a
particular chapter it's worked it
absolutely works and you have to do it
in every corner like literally every
corner of the house I had a blasting
through the speaker like we're on repeat
listen and I was going through every
corner and it was gone call your friend
I have no problem doing it get them back
in there get get the Quran get them back
in there have them start reading the
prayers this thing is out of here it'll
be gone
this is wild it gives me it gives me
chills bro this is so I got a full
apparitions the whole body is filled
with chills bro dude when I saw that
seriously the same thing right now I got
goosebumps
[Laughter]
[Music]
maybe shouldn't have probably put up
their video of them you know on a
national Forum but like I couldn't I
could not believe this they moved out
this is yes yes the next here's the
thing if you don't deal with it they can
actually follow you you know so it's
like it's about it's about like taking
care of it so that ghost could just go
with them to the next house they can go
wherever they want this the whole thing
is they catch on to you they could yeah
they could well you're not only supposed
to see a psychic that attaches to you
too
[ __ ] these psychics bro all of them is
tarot cards all that [ __ ] you don't know
the whole point is I hate these [ __ ]
Ghost Hunter shows and all these things
I can't [ __ ] stand it it's called The
Unseen for a reason you don't know what
it is these [ __ ] are walking in like
there's a nine-year-old daughter this
girl is stuck here come on out Denise
come on out it's okay say something
scrap [ __ ] you don't know if it's a
demon disguised as a nine-year-old girl
bro shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up I never thought about
that
show demon in Disguise that's the name
it's called a 90 it's called the Unseen
for a reason we pitched the show where
we we pitch a show at the guys called
not haunted where we would go like it's
a goat
anti-go like it was a get to Ghost
Hunter show it plays like a ghost hunter
show we were pitching is not but we
would go to these people that think they
have haunted houses set up everything do
the whole thing and then just prove
there's no one there and like the
conclusion was like the house is not
haunted
single episode
yeah bro I don't I don't trust I've gone
through other foot how long were they
living we don't know I got this a few
months ago they texted me I I could yeah
can we find out where they live yeah or
I'm gonna go help them out right now
yeah let's go yeah but so so you saw
them playing I I the first time I showed
me it I didn't see it and then I just
showed me again I didn't see it and then
they go just pay attention I looked I
was like and she goes can you play the
whole thing there was no one in the home
and they don't live with anyone else and
they saw that after the fact
that's so I mean there's no there's no
there's no denying that that is a
[ __ ] body walking by no oh my god
when they saw it played it back on video
yeah they didn't know in the moment yeah
when it come when the ring comes back
when the camera moves back I thought I
saw something on that side but
is she pointing though at the end like I
saw something oh no no she doesn't even
know
yo that's so yeah I'm wondering if the
camera is like I picked it up I was told
to me they freaked out they moved out
the next day
yeah it's those golf clubs that did it
probably
so like if you see do you see any like
do you see almost the back half of a
body and hair do you see any like pink
robes do you see I thought it was yellow
but do you you don't see even legs no I
only see I it literally I mean it's it I
know this is too much yeah I don't see
anything that is insane that's so creepy
bro I don't even see ankles so I totally
don't blame them I don't blame them from
leaving that that out so you but you
wouldn't say a prayer what do you mean
would you say your prayer and stay or
would you leave yeah I would do it I
would do it anyway I would do it either
way whether I decide
I would it would be like I'm talking
about at least an hour of just complete
cleansing of the whole at least I have a
friend of mine when he when he got his
house his teacher came and cleansed the
whole house he was there for 24 hours he
said no just leave me here and he went
to every corner of the house and just
pay well prayed on it yeah he did it for
free hours he loves the same teacher
what do you mean teacher like a school
teacher no no I'm saying like uh like a
scholar of religion a theologian oh
Theologian yeah particularly in in Islam
yeah but understand that full
understanding of all religions like
they're they're like oceans of knowledge
bro they're like unbelievably oh yeah
they know they know everything yeah yeah
I mean they sit there that's all they do
every day like they just read and write
and Converse they speak like you know
six seven languages
I'm super blessed to even know these
people yeah Theologian on the pot yeah
yeah yeah but the people I know they
would walk away were just like this
guy's talking about dick sucking Moment
On Top
these are like really believing men you
know like a real Theologian would sit
here and try to they try to turn me no
they wouldn't they try to figure me out
no I think they didn't figure out the
moment they walk in and just be like
they're incredibly perceptive human
beings yeah he's not maybe maybe Delilah
is going to be a theologian yeah maybe
that's the job Delilah I think Delilah
is going to be a theologian look he made
it about her again
[Laughter]
although that's what
that's what you can't just like you
gotta get a professional not some
[ __ ] [ __ ] from a Discovery Channel
you know what I mean like I don't know
what I would do I don't know what I
would do if that happened if I was in
that if that happened to me I don't know
what I would do because I don't know
when the next time I would be able to
not feel unsettled is like you can't
like you can't see that I'm unsettled
now if I was one of those two girls I
might have to go get some help like
therapy like I know you should get some
professionals yeah that's the whole
point yeah where do you get it from also
is really important like you know one of
the things I was taught like be careful
of who you get your religion from who
you get your information from because
you could be misguided so easily yeah
and then it can make matters even worse
so it's really really important to
understand like the knowledge that
you're attaining making sure like it is
correct it has like a chain of of being
passed down and authenticated by like 95
of Scholars around the world like you
got to make sure because like you guys
less than 10 years ago I used to get my
religion from some guy in Kenosha and it
was like totally yeah
it's like important stuff people should
know man people give so misguided then
all of a sudden they believe this like
it's everything and the next you know
fights and [ __ ] happens the next year
war starts that's exactly how it happens
no religion is the thing that causes the
war yeah sure okay
religion is the thing that's the that's
the one I think the people are the one
who do no dude if there was no religion
there'd be no war would there be that
true would there be because
absolutely no rules and people will just
absolutely start murdering
no Wars in Palestine in Europe there's
nothing to do with religion dude are you
out of your mind
I think religion does but you're saying
religion doesn't kill people people kill
people absolutely people kill people
people absolutely the Bible has been
Rewritten how many times by who at least
five by who um I don't know who wrote
Kings Kings yeah you know Matthew Mark
Luke and John I'm saying like this whole
thing and I believe in this like I
believe in all of it I believe are you
religious I believe I believe I'm a
believing part like it depends what your
definition of religious is dude he he
literally he he just told you he just
hangs out with a theologians
thank you
guys religious I like that bro you know
I live a life I mean how you know I'm
just like always touring doing a thing
I'm living the same life but you know I
do have like people that I can call in
times where [ __ ] like this happen right
I can reach out I think religion is I
think also religion is whatever your
ability no but this is very important
like what is your definition of religion
because I'm like you know certain
atheists I know that are tell me they're
atheists and I find out what their
belief system is what they what their
issue is I'm like yeah I agree with you
I agree with all the [ __ ] you're saying
so under that standard like I get it I
get why you're so completely turned off
I believe in a higher power I believe me
too there is a lot to me is like the T
you know uh uh Yusuf was like a
incredible again just an incredible
human being in scholar he said that um
he says your incomprehension of God is
your comprehension of God right you know
what I mean that's all that's what I
believe it like I believe in something
that's so incredibly infinite and big
that I my brain should that week
whenever you try to describe it your
brain should short search it yeah yeah
you know what I mean that's what I
believe I believe too like like your own
relationship whatever your relationship
is with whatever your God is to you
that's that's all that matters for me
anybody
yeah that's okay that's the thing
to Die For A Cause nationalism religion
to me that's like archaic like that's
like that's that's the old model of the
human brain like it's ridiculous to
wanna like when I would I just came from
from from Ireland and when I saw these
people who were like willing to like die
for their country I understand I respect
it but I was like I just don't have that
in me I'm like why it's lines on a map
or religion it's just something that
another human being the higher power is
the higher power but the vessel that
tells it is a human being so I can't
trust that the human being knows what
they have the relationship with the
vessel with the higher power but I don't
you know what you know what I'm trying
to say I do and but when you were just
doing that you accidentally like you
didn't know it but you went like this
my family's very religious yeah and I am
not but my family is I give him again
it's like what is the definition I'm not
a religious person if based on your
definition which I'm kind of feeling out
I'm not a religious person I don't think
any of us based on your definition but I
pray you know what I mean like so do I
that's like you know like I remember one
of my friends
one of my friends was trying to pray
yeah you know if you would have prayed
you would have gotten a better hat
no that escaped our relationships
I think Mom would agree you see what I'm
saying it's eased it up baby
prayer is meditation to me yeah it's the
same thing that's what it is okay so you
meditate
uh uh father-son Holy Spirit then in our
father Hail Mary and then I ask uh God
whatever my God is my God there's only
one bro one over the entire universe no
it's God you can say God like whatever
somebody says like whatever God is your
Gods there's God there's one he has the
higher confident power over everything I
talked to that higher power briefly and
just asked to have whatever for whatever
I'm asking for does this come do you
have a routine like is it before bed
when you wake up is it could you be
driving in a cold shower right no really
when do you pray I pray typically in the
morning when I wake up and at night uh
before I go to bed and if there ever is
this is just a dumb human brain if there
ever is a moment of uh like high anxiety
in my day I pray that I I understand I
do understand that the healing power
that is prayer for people that's that's
your relationship with yourself I'm just
shocked because I didn't know you did it
because you never ever talk about I I
haven't prayed I should see what it's
like I haven't prayed so good why don't
you guys are amazing you know you know
it's you know it's so amazing hour
already
that's very important I don't want to
cut this short no this is yeah I reflect
but I'm never really praying to anyone
I'm just reflecting and being like but
no it's good man it's actually a really
good thing like the way the way it's
described in Islam like prayer has been
prescribed to you is prescription it's
medication right so this is Blue Shield
I am no but it's like their spiritual
illnesses too man people are like
[ __ ] lost people are popping pills
left to right people like said they
don't know what the [ __ ] to do with it
they don't know where the channel this
emotion go to a doctor doctor gives you
a pill that's not actually helping but
you're making matters worse is addiction
issues people start going off and it's
actually like a spiritual thing it's
like something's going on in people's
hearts man people are like confused they
don't know which way to go who am I what
do I believe in what sex am I what's
going on am I this or my dad I'm my
parents are divorced this thing is going
on they have no [ __ ] Direction so
they turn to a doctor gives them pill
they're supposed to make [ __ ] better
pharmaceutical companies don't give a
[ __ ] about you sure and so this is a
form of like spending time with yourself
and just breathing all this is part of
like
my definition I'm not I would say like
hanging out with you I would say like no
I'm not religious I'm spiritual and then
with other people their definition of
religious because I could I could be
somebody like yeah I'm religious and
they're fanatical I'm like whoa I'm not
that bro right I'm a spiritual like
believing person right but this is like
you're off The Rocker yeah so that's why
it's like everything is like the middle
but a lot of extremists are the ones
that right of course that that's the
point because potion in anything is bad
that's that's what I was trying to
that's what I was trying to say before
is you and I we're the same we're both
we're spiritual than that but you're
saying but that's why I was saying
religion is the thing that causes the
war because religion is we're both
saying well this is the way I do it and
there's no flexibility and that's what
causes the but at the end of the day
well these are misguided exactly yeah
these are misguided people and honestly
most of the time it's all based off of
money it all comes down to power and
it's yeah and the religion aspect of it
is used to control the people and so you
get them on your way to do that I
wouldn't did shows in Iraq bro in Kuwait
in Iraq and soldiers were crying bro
soldiers would cry with me and [ __ ] and
one of them was telling me everything
that they did to them before they
released them into Iraq which had
nothing to do with 9 11 and they sent
them there and they gave this whole
[ __ ] pep talk to These Guys these
people hate Jesus and we're gonna go out
there and visit the [ __ ] are you talking
about we believe in Jesus man we believe
in this we believe it we believe in uh
we believe in Jesus we you know
Islam you know like we believe in him
like it's just outrageous that's what
they do but they're using that against
them to fuel them to go murder innocent
people so it's like [ __ ] you man I
believe in people I love everyone from
any background I don't give a [ __ ]
believer non-believer I don't care I
really don't care right I think that I I
just think like you know I'm a man of
the people I love the people I think
then in the end you know everybody has
their issues and even if they're mad or
somebody goes off on me or somebody goes
off like oh they're they're troubled
there's something going on it's hard to
like control your emotions with that but
it's like you know I think in the end
like people are always searching and
they want to feel good you know they
want to feel better that's it that's
what it is did you see religious can you
hear the pineapple
[Music]
religious oh yeah I've seen it a long
time ago it's a doc by Bill Maher yeah
about about religion it's pretty good
it's pretty good but I'm going to just
say this you know Bill Maher shouldn't
be uh anywhere near religious you should
be near religion politics
is all I'm saying sure and I also
believe that he should never touch
anything related to religion or be an
actual uh you know uh he's not a
journalist he's a you know he's very
clear what he believes in yeah he's just
like he's like whatever that's what he
is tomorrow no I haven't a story like
that we were uh this is when Eddie
Murphy did SNL oh and I was like the 40s
I went yeah I tell you I'll tell you so
I go and Dave was topping on and
Chappelle's pop it on and Chris Rock I
think Tracy Morgan walked on as well I
was like man I got to go to this so I
text Dave was like I'm coming yeah I'd
even be like can I go I was like yo I'm
coming my brother I'm coming you know
like I love you but I'm going so I went
and I just couldn't believe it [ __ ]
Eddie Murphy after like 37 years it's
coming back on SNL it was Liz I was a
musical guest who's from Houston the
same neighborhood I'm very confident
very very cool yeah very confident and I
get there and I'm watching the show is
incredible all this I looked down I was
like I'm gonna take this cover sheet
from SNL The Script you know they had it
there and I was like you know what I'm
taking this smart I'm gonna put it in my
pocket like this and then Dave is
looking for he wants to get his cue
cards and Sam Jay you guys know Sam sure
so so
Jay she gets Dave his cue cards from SNL
you know his line that he delivers she
brings it to him and then Dave goes come
on and I think we're my head he goes
something about lizzo I was like okay
he's gonna go introduce me to lizzo I'm
shooting my shot at a leaf it's probably
introducing us for that reason Bobby
dope we go we walk here if it's a
neighborhood in Houston the neighborhood
yeah neighborhood filming series we walk
in it's Eddie Murphy's Green Room I was
like oh [ __ ] and we've met before once
before at the Palladium when Dave filmed
this special there's age of Spin and uh
and uh Dave has this cue card we're like
kids you know he's like I've never seen
Dave like wow that's like happy you know
that's cool himself looking into the
goat you know like looking at the you
know and Eddie he was like would you
sign this cue card for me like that he
was like of course of course of course
and I was just like [ __ ] would you say
this oh you had to I had to you would
you say this for me you had to pass in
that moment
no way and so Dave introduced me into my
you know uh this is Moe you open a
tunnel of the road like brother he has a
special on Netflix at that point it was
just the Vagabond at that time and he
signed up he's like man I'm gonna check
out your special run he signs it to me
and he put it on there and I got so
excited I forgot Dave forgot to ask Dave
to sign the thing too but I got it all
framed you think he really watched the
special Eddie Murphy uh Dave said that
he's gonna watch it the guy is like
apparently the guy is just um watches a
ton of colors what you do if he watched
it and he was like I have notes I have
notes yeah
I just reached out and asked me to go
and I was like I cannot believe I cannot
attend why I don't remember what it was
for but I remember being like
heartbroken for so long oh man it was
one of the most incredible maybe it was
like he wasn't on any other time right
no no
stand up again but he he didn't no he
didn't maybe he still will he could
easily do it though but she probably
tells me he's like crazy funny like
every time they go hang out she's just
like basically just in jokes he just
speaks that language you know yeah so he
speaks I wonder what his material will
be now though because it's such it's
gonna be such a departure from what it
was like it is it is weird the reason he
was not it wasn't getting back to it for
so long was because he he said himself
this is what I read is that it's
impossible it's I can't win like I can't
live up to what has been well he's just
so famous yeah you know it's like he's
so famous people like freak out around
Eddie and when he got to that point
where he's so wildly famous it was hard
to go back how do you go back to stand
up from 30 years ago the thing is that
Dave never stopped doing standing right
so if he didn't stop
it would have helped sure
and he's in the conversation of goat of
all time stop for 10 years
he did take you know a break but he was
still doing shows like he was still okay
he would still go to DC do like pop-ups
and stuff like that he would do all
these announcements Dave was like I
think he was in Portland or something
and he was in a skate shop buying some
shoes and he told a couple people in the
shop that he's gonna do a show in the
middle of the square in Portland and
then he showed up with a mic and a and a
and a little speaker and then it was 10
000 people there wow they call it
Chappelle stock he didn't know that many
people were going to show up one person
started texting another person one
person I mean but that might have been
like the city probably like that person
was chaos chaos and he just showed up
into the park like this with a little
speaker and a mic and he thought nobody
could even hear in the back like it just
became like crazy dude yeah he was like
yeah I want to do a show so he was doing
stuff like that
[Laughter]
I asked him I was like I have a feeling
that you want to do one tomorrow night
too like I just had that feeling he was
like we asked we can't it's too it's
booked
hey babe no well what can you do this is
this is I missed you it was so great to
catch up
in uh Arabic
I didn't have beef tea
this has been this says how do you say
this has been hey babe in Arabic this
has been this has been hey babe in
Arabic we don't really talk like that
this has been how would you say
foreign
Back to the Future cause 9 11.
watch Mo on Netflix yes watch
Black Adam movie comes out this Friday
it's so exciting special on Netflix
specials on that Mohammed in Texas in
the Vagabond but enjoy this enjoy the
enjoy the series Mo it's about my life
it's very personal uh episode five six
seven eight like just like some of my
favorite like finishing run in a series
like enjoy it congratulations on
everything yeah thank you so much it
also makes the best lentil soup you've
ever had in your life ever had in your
life it'll knock the socks that you're
not wearing off
little bitty sauce
all right thank you baby
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe
[Music]